thank you
[Music]
do you know what Peta is what are you
looking at dude
you're looking so closely look right
here do what are you doing over there
look over there do you know what Peta is
uh pet
yeah it is
oh very good middle eastern bread but
it's good bread yeah one of my favorite
hummus oh are you about to talk about
hummus chickpeas
which is um cilantro I'm allowed to let
this go for 45 seconds before I really
back I like lamb
I like oh are you gonna talk about lamb
yes okay so speaking of uh animals Pita
stands for people for the ethical
treatment of animals oh not Peter they
should be put
people for the prophetola
yeah yeah I think I think that would be
difficult for people
um but yes Animal Welfare organization
Peta has come up with a new idea to
convince men
to switch to being vegan
now why men only why men because there
is this very uh masculine machismo
concept that men eat meat you gotta eat
your protein more men are like the flag
bearers that champion the idea of eating
animals and bulking up and blah blah
blah it's just like a natural thing that
men constantly wanted better for the
games yeah it's better for the game
speak on it you got some games
I know right I'm eating beef jerky right
now just sitting there on the side all
casual you all the good games
look at that dude it just tastes good
it's all man baby that's all made by
beef yeah I didn't associate masculinity
with protein meat well it's some people
do some people do when they're trying to
think of different Avenues to get more
people to search the vegans so we are
all a collective of Creative Marketing
professionals I would say I want us to
take our honest judgment on this
marketing campaign that they are trying
to put into effect in order to convince
more men to switch to being vegan you
know how many hot ass girls are vegan
all the [ __ ] models all of them all
the [ __ ] Instagram models they're
[ __ ] so Peta is asking women to go on
a sex strike against meat eaters
you can't hit this [ __ ] until you eat
[ __ ] asparagus that might work or
don't eat meat that's gonna work on a
very small population does sex strikes
historically work out yeah for women's
uh uh rights when they wanted to vote
no it's true it's true they're they
women suffrage was they're like yeah I
ain't gonna give you no [ __ ] [ __ ]
until you give me the right to vote yeah
that's a big cause though I got a lot of
women on one team I feel like women that
are vegan I feel very small popular
because the husbands were the only ones
that were allowed to vote at the time so
then the husbands were like I can't
[ __ ] survive man get no [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm going crazy man yeah just let them
vote just let him [ __ ] vote and then
they all went in and then the the women
that's actually pretty fascinating I
didn't know that's what happened so
blanket statement we would objectively
be like there's Merit to this Marketing
Concept it's just not the largest enough
pool I think so me personally I think it
could it'll probably work but there's
zero in a very small you mean a zero
Merit I think so you're a little okay
you can't hit this puss puss unless you
stop eating meat you don't think there's
some dudes that would [ __ ] I think
that would suck but I think that would
work I think dudes just be like then I
won't hit that plus plus I'll hit that
plus plus but who do you imagine doing
this are you matching like a really hot
girl that you already well first of all
we're imagining we're imagining all
women are on the same page they are well
not all of them there's two there's two
the ones watching Bachelorette are yeah
there's there's regular women I love it
when we all talk about it and there's
gold diggers gold diggers love
they love the gold the good life right
good life involves steak
so of course they're gonna be like hey
gold digger right here [ __ ] me all you
want and you can eat all the steak you
want and all the guys just go okay I'm
coming over here now I haven't met a
vegan gold digger that's true but those
are the guys with money though right
then the guys that don't have money they
gotta go vegan they go I guess I'm not
eating steak in it see that's the
compromise it's gonna go two pools it's
just gonna be Californians that are
withholding [ __ ] 100 yeah I don't see
anybody from like Nevada or Texas or
whatever that
uh shut up
for like on the front page of the New
York Times Californians withholding
[ __ ] because there's no [ __ ] vegan
restaurants in Illinois or [ __ ]
Montana there's no [ __ ] vegan
restaurants there's no market for it how
many women are are withholding [ __ ]
though because they like they like
penises too have you ever ran into a
situation where you were about to have
sex with a girl and she said I'm sorry
I'm withholding [ __ ] at the moment has
that ever happened to Anthony Lee not to
Anthony Lee
if you're a [ __ ] steak eater has that
ever happened to anything I suck in your
dick well you ran into a sex strike and
you were like oh [ __ ] never no I never
experienced a sex strike only when I was
a part of a church
I would say I would say religion is the
only time that [ __ ] has been withheld
but then they'll still give you hand
jobs but they still do yeah there's
loopholes there wow she'll do anal have
you ever had that experience before what
they had to withhold the vagina because
of their religion but they gave you anal
uh entrance you just brought up the anal
experience and I asked you about it and
you're like what are you talking about
talk about the anal experience like it's
a [ __ ] show
so has that ever happened to you I
apologize thank you
no I it has not happened not yet though
I never experienced this extract okay if
you ask nicely you're very formal dude I
say can you please and they go okay
it works every time okay bye he goes all
you gotta do is bust out the pretty
please yeah if they say sex strike
because you're a meat eater you go oh
but please they go I guess I mean I I
think they're underestimating how many
guys actually lie about being vegan just
over girls too oh my God it's a very
easy life but unless you put in your
Instagram bio then or even how many guys
lie about the religion just so they get
the puss puss hey that's true or how
many guys join clubs they don't even
want to [ __ ] join but because they
want to get the [ __ ] what clubs was
that all the clubs in college you wanted
to [ __ ] someone in Kansas I was just
trying to meet chicks I joined all the
clubs in college that was that was the
origin of the dance Journey for me the
puss puss withholding might work though
because there's a lot of things guys do
just for the Post dude I could see if
all the women could agree but those
[ __ ] can't agree
so if they can't agree then there's only
going to be like 10 that are that are
vegan and are withholding and the other
90 and it's not even they need to agree
on like withholding vagina if they first
need to agree that the vegan way is the
right the right way that's true plus
even if you're talking vegan there's
there's unlimited amounts of ways that
you are vegan there's like so many
subsets and then we're not even just
describing the fact that he gave a
really good point that it's like they
want a dick too and then I I think that
sometimes they will be like yeah I would
never give this guy unless he doesn't
eat meat but then on the side she's
getting [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
[Music]
you know but I feel like veganism for a
lot of people is a very high moral High
Ground right so then they're going to be
like dude this is all that matters
because a lot you me I've met some vegan
not many but like one or two that are
very strong with how they feel about
veganism so I feel like they're the ones
that are gonna be in the Front Runners
that are gonna be turning all the dudes
also veganism so intercompetitive like
you can have one person that just
doesn't eat meat and then another person
that's like making sure your curtains
aren't made of platypus or something
so many levels and one vegan can always
call out another for not being vegan
unlimitedly yeah unlimited you're not
gangster enough you know Actually I
don't even think this is a problem for
dudes because I've never met a hot vegan
because if all the vegans are ugly right
and they're like you can't hit this like
I don't want to hit that anymore
but also we live in California we all we
do live show me a whole list of all the
Instagram models are hot vegans but
they're also they're gold diggers and
they eat steak with Dan bazarian
yeah so they're so they're just vegan on
the front I'm talking about real vegans
no everyone's a [ __ ] fake vegan
because if you're a real vegan you can't
be having no LV purse made out of
[ __ ] no yeah you're right that's what
I'm saying the levels that's what I'm
talking about if you're real you can't
sit in an Uber that's got leather seats
exactly a real there's no such thing as
a real hot vegan I feel like they're all
I think they're like they're just
basically like cosplay vegan
they have vegan on their Instagram title
but they're like cosplay it does take a
lot they're going to live in a real
vegan a lot of work [ __ ] be
vegetarian thinking that's vegan here's
another uh
data concept that's being toyed within
conversation that I'm sure will weigh in
an opinion on they talk about
um their scientific proof that toxic
masculinity also harms the climate
therefore a hefty meat tax of 41 for men
would be appropriate the 41 comes from
research uh that reveals that men cause
41 more greenhouse gas emissions than
women because of their meat eating
Tendencies let's just throw down numbers
man yeah 41 is they're causing
um the the ozone layer whole yeah yeah
that's basically one of those if a
equals b and b equals c then a equals c
loopholes you know what they should have
done it's way better they should have
been like men fart way [ __ ] more so
they should be taxed for [ __ ]
creating those emissions yeah I think
that that makes way more sense girl I
think girls fight the same I agree yeah
I agree I think they do the exact same
you think they produce the same amount
of gas emissions because we're like
these trucks and they're like they're
more like yeah they're like Fiats you
know we just have more audio yeah when
it comes to the when it comes to the 41
attacks I could cut meat like that
because I'm Chinese at the end of the
day ah okay oh never mind can we think
of ways that this could like what's a
real way to actually get you to be vegan
that you think would work get people to
be vegan yeah make sure that's one way
you would I will okay I would say make
it cheaper make it more delicious and
those are the two things that could be
and make me full or put poison in all
the cows
oh have you guys been to like a vegan
restaurant yeah my whole life my mom's
vegetarian anytime anytime I've eaten at
a vegan restaurant it's very good
they're really good but afterwards I'm
starving I'm like I'm ravenous
afterwards does that happen to you too
they're really good and then I have the
best shits the next day yeah because of
all the fiber and stuff all the veggies
yeah but I do feel like my [ __ ] like
my Beta inside it comes out yeah
and like kind of unpleasant and it just
makes me not want to be like them so
whether they're yeah they play with
[ __ ] Legos I'm not gonna do what they
do yeah just because I don't think
they're happy yeah like are you really
happy screaming at me because of your
lifestyle that's it I remember one time
we went to a like a coffee shop that had
like a lot of vegan products and then I
never had anything vegan before and it
was a brownie and she goes yeah it's a
vegan brownie and I'm like oh I never
had that before what you know what's in
it and she had this like uh it's no
dairy products and I'm all like [ __ ]
why you so condescending about it like I
don't [ __ ] know yeah why can't you
just be like oh it's you know like you
never had it well here let me [ __ ]
sell it to you you just lost the [ __ ]
yeah person that could have been like
what we're veganism there's there's
toxic masculine men that are nicer to me
than that yeah right 100 that's what I
mean because that goes for even like
carnivorism right like people that are
into the carnivore lifestyle if they're
really aggressive and really trying to
like convert you it's the same thing as
I'm like I'm not gonna eat all meat
either because [ __ ] like you
but you're like well
yeah yeah and spite that's what I do
yeah [ __ ] vegans dude
[Music]
[Music]